today on stick to football we are
breaking down the weekend to come a
little bit of news and notes college
football weekend previews and picks also
our top five people that we would
impeach from sports we're sticking to
sports today we're sticking a football
Melo will be joining us shortly running
a little late from the day job Connor
and I you can see us on YouTube right
now Bleacher Report's channel follow the
six football playlist what a man I like
that camo hoodie you look good
thanks buddy what's going on it's a
lovely day I do want to tell people we
are coming up very closely the Kansas
City Chiefs tailgate it's for Sunday
Night Football Colts at Chiefs it's
gonna be a fantastic game the tailgate
will start at 3 p.m. in Lot J so if you
come in gate 7 lot J is right there I
would recommend buying your parking pass
ahead of time because they're very
expensive if you don't but operation BBQ
relief will be there cooking up food
we're gonna do the podcast there's gonna
be a DJ there's gonna be it's basically
like a petting zoo for adults it's just
gonna be a good time so come out I'm
sure we'll have some Nattie's and some
boulevards because we're in KC yeah it
looked absolutely crazy on opening
weekend out in Kansas City
I saw people lined up in it's pitch
black outside yeah like how how early
did they open the gates before the game
five or six five hours but the cool
thing about where Arrowhead and Kauffman
are you get off the interstate and
you're kind of secluded so what we have
done what a lot of our friends will do
in those situations is just go get in
line for the gates go ahead and throw it
in park turn the car off you got a
cooler in the back and you can just have
some beers while you wait for the gate -
Oh / so you're tailgating before you're
tailgating it's one of the beautiful
things about Kansas City we do have some
news actually happening around the
league right now we have the art king
whose dad came out this week and said
he's transferring he's gonna leave he's
gonna transfer and then Derek said uh no
not actually gonna transfer and Connor
you just asked me before the show like
so wait what what did happen with this
so dear King has decided to take
advantage of a loophole of a rule
basically and he he is going to redshirt
this year because he has appeared in
four games or less so he can redshirt
and maintain one year of eligibility now
the crazy thing is he can do this and
transfer still he's big
they said he won't but he could if he
does not like where things are headed
with Dana Holgorsen and and Houston has
struggled this year so it'll be
interesting to see what king does he was
not the only one their best receiver
keith corbin actually he's doing the
same thing both players are gonna
redshirt yeah so this kind of preserves
obviously how long not only that they
could stay at Houston but their college
football career so I don't think all the
wild rumors of him leaving yet are
completely gone especially I know the
Oklahoma one was kind of hot out that at
the same time Matt I think they're okay
at quarterback
even after Jalen hurts so it was a
little weird but of course Lincoln Riley
has talked up the air King before I
think his dad made this very confusing
right off the top parents out there you
don't always need to speak for your kids
especially when they're an athlete but I
think at the end of the day this is
where it's been solved he will redshirt
maybe you know there'll be a little bit
more comfort it's not on him that
Houston has had an up-and-down start the
Dana Holgorsen era it's a team thing but
what a weird absolutely kind of weird
couple days it was of confusion now Matt
I'm wondering what is your taken and
what do you think the reason truly is
for Derrick doing this you know I think
the biggest thing is maybe more time to
get comfortable with this system is one
thing that I've heard any especially
with Corbin doing this too is may be
both guys want to kind of take some time
to hey let's let's take a step back and
we'll have the year to basically
practice and train and get healthy and
then come in next you're more familiar
but I'll tell you Scouts are not happy
um I didn't even reach out about this
because I don't think Derrick Kings an
NFL prospect at quarterback necessarily
sure but I had some people reach out to
me one guy was so pissed about this he
was like let me tell you I'll play any
player that does this is automatically
off this guy's board now the team could
still say hey we want you to go evaluate
Jarrett King but this Scout told me I
would not put him on my board this he
said it was selfish said it was entitled
and they're like basically this is the
problem with Millennials now I don't
necessarily agree with this god knows
they're right the rules are there for
you to take advantage of and that's what
you're doing I actually think is pretty
smart we've now used to everyone do this
uh Kelly Bryant did it last year he left
Clemson but he left Clemson he took his
redshirt went to Mizzou I I think it's
kind of brilliant honestly I'm Dana
Holgorsen spart on Derek
part but I had another guy reach out not
quite as scorched-earth but he said
maybe this allows the air King a chance
to move to receiver because I know
that's where a lot of people see his
future I don't think that's gonna happen
but it is interesting to kind of see the
mindsets of how the NFL have used the
situation like this I hope he plays
quarterback next year just because he's
an exciting college quarterback to watch
as much as of course we always and we're
guilty of this more than anyone getting
caught up in a guy's future in the NFL
and I think when you look at it for dear
King I think this would be maybe viewed
as a selfish situation if it was a coach
on the hot seat but Dana Holgorsen is
expected to be at Houston for a very
long time this is the beginning of an
era I could see them working together on
this where it's not a selfish situation
it's more just that they're a little bit
more hopeful for next year right now
they're kind of hitting a little bit of
a reset button or putting things on
pause so I have no problem with it at
all yeah I don't either another player
who's making news that's Melvin Gordon
who ended his holdout today on Thursday
reported to the Los Angeles chargers
basically loses two point two million
dollars so a sizable chunk of change
that he will have a chance to make back
he will be a free agent after this year
the expectation is he will leave the
Chargers we'll look to hit free agency
hopefully they don't slap the franchise
tag on him because they have the ability
to do that but it sounds like this will
be an amicable split they'd like Austin
Eckler it's a very deep running back
class the 2020 group with John Taylor
down dry Swift Travis etn and those are
just around one guys in round two you
could talk about you know cam Akers now
Shea Harris you know Benjamin Keyshawn
Vaughn a lot of talented players who
could be day two guys I think it's
notable that Melvin Gordon kind of
realized that they had called his
[ __ ] where he was like now I'm gonna
blow I'm gonna hold out there like okay
go ahead have fun they lasted three
weeks yeah it didn't work I think that's
the takeaway right here it did not
backfired very quickly we had talked
about over summer that this was always a
little bit of a dangerous game because
this wasn't a sequel Elliott we're a day
three rookie was behind him on the
roster even though Toni Pollard looks
good this was Austin Eckler who has
shined when Melvin Gordon's been hurt
now it's a spin this thing kind of
forward the Chargers are a surprising
one-and two-and that
one win was an overtime win against the
Colts now things get very easy they play
the Dolphins Broncos Steelers and Titans
next they'll probably turn this thing
around even if they do and this offense
is spun a link through Austin Eckler
right now Matt do you think there's any
chance they can look to move Melvin
Gordon at the deadline because yes if
they let him walk you get a compensatory
pick and it'll probably be a third-round
pick but as I always say they probably
want to speed it up filbert is getting
old
the third-round pick would be earlier
than a compensatory pick and if just in
case you get some desperate teams maybe
you get a second-round pick I'm just
saying
is there any chance Melvin Gordon could
get moved still at the oh absolutely
him reporting means you could trade us
ass right now basically I mean he's
reported he's on the team you could
trade him the thing is like it goes back
to what we talked about over the summer
who would want him you know buffaloes
three you know right now yeah Frank Gore
they have Devin Singletary
I don't know Serafima would would be
willing to take a flyer on a running
back you know that the rest the AFC East
in turn any one NFC North is actually
pretty set AFC South not bad right now I
can't see anyone mortgaging you know
like you said a second or third I'm pick
right now to get that guy because that
we don't have that team at this point
that looks like okay if they just had a
running back they would be more in
contention so I think a market would be
pretty weak for him right now even like
the 49ers to be the one team where
they've lost some superstars but Matt
breda and Rahim muster to getting it
done so you wouldn't want to trade for a
guy because you just really don't need
him to get the job done man you know
what I always say you could play me or
Melo in Kyle Shanahan's run system and I
think we'd have a chance I want to try
may even get a little yarder to you on a
couple of plays right we've run the
old-school wishbone you and I at
tailback Melo fullback and and we just
[ __ ] crush people I think we could do
it one last thing that we're gonna talk
about Shea Patterson is probable against
Rutgers what are the chances he's hurt
versus the chances that Jim Harbaugh was
just done and has decided he's not good
and is going to list him as injured the
rest of the year because that's my
conspiracy it doesn't matter because
it's too late it's over so this was
always a mistake we said it was a
mistake over summer
Patterson's not very good I'm sorry Shay
Patterson when it comes down to it this
could cost Jim Harbaugh his job because
he was a little stubborn with Shay
Patterson now I will say this after
going to the game on Saturday it's not
like people were constantly open where I
could put it all on Shay Patterson but
at the end of the day he has struggled
for quite some time
I think he's held this offense back they
have a lot of talent at wide receiver
I think Michigan's probably looking to
inject some life into this lifeless
season and that's probably why that he's
listed as her right now Matt it's
amazing it's simply amazing that defense
I know I've said it a couple times on
the show no the defense just so
disappointing all right let's take a
break we'll get Melo in here we come
back with our top five and college
football weekend preview picks and don't
forget blind review is gonna be in
segment two this week I know you guys
are all looking forward to it I love it
alright we are back Melo is here again
check us out on YouTube he's rockin that
stick to football polo bleacher report
youtube channel every Monday Wednesday
Friday you'll get new shows all right
let's jump into week four NFL week five
college football previews and picks and
I'm gonna start it with number twelve
Penn State is - six-and-a-half at
Maryland the over/under and this one
guys is set at 61 and a half and Connor
joined a week late on the picks he and I
are tied at 60% mellows at 64% show off
I feel like this week I'm catching your
ass folks I'm on one game back I'm
taking Penn State in this one I do not
know if they cover though that's where
I'm at they really have this is a Penn
State team I still don't know who they
are because they haven't really beat
anyone this year we saw Maryland has
been up and down but we know they can
score a lot of points this is a big game
for guys like Micah Parsons at
linebacker but I am taking Penn State
but I would not take them to cover
yeah and that's where I think you're
right I'm actually gonna go with
Maryland this is our first let me get it
up here so I say it right the super
underdog locksmith game of the week to
bet your money on because I don't have
the nuts to bet my own money on you are
absolutely right about Penn State they
have not been tested by anyone yet they
killed Iowa or not Idaho there we go
they kill different
Oh bye 79 and everybody got all excited
but remember they don't even have a
quarterback yeah Sean Clifford has not
looked impressive at all the running
game has been hit and miss they've
they've had some production but at the
same time you struggled against Illinois
when you're going against Maryland in
conference I really think that this is a
trap game for Penn State if they
overlook Maryland because they're not
ranked they're just gonna get rolled
over
I like Maryland I like the fact that
they have a bye and that Loxley can go
get creative on offense he can come up
with some new ways to get their
playmakers the ball because the problem
is going to be this Penn State defense
led by Michael Parsons they're just
unstoppable but with that bye week both
teams have a bye I think that Josh
Jackson little booger McFarland can get
things going enough to beat Penn State
that's why I'm calling for an upset
upset here with our first game it's a
Friday night game too so we'll see if
that factors in yeah for me McFarland
might be the guy that's the x-factor in
this one I just think his outside speed
can heat you know those linebackers
obviously Michael Parsons has great
speed can't he break off a big play can
they get him involved in the passing
offense I think Maryland's offense is
really really impressive but I'm gonna
go with Penn State because I do think
the defense will finally will shut them
down I think Marilyn will finally run
into a little bit of a wall here I do
agree with Melo that Penn State has not
been tested yet I feel like we don't
know much about this team yet where we
could sit here and say yes they should
be in the top 15 but right now they
haven't lost they are and I think this
will be a close game I think that lines
pretty big but I think they sneaked out
the win all right number 18 Virginia at
number 10 Notre Dame Notre Dame was
favored by 12 and a half the over/under
48 and a half Virginia struggled with
Old Dominion last week I think that's
one of the big takeaways for me here's
they did now here's the thing I also
don't know if Notre Dame can stop Bryce
Perkins who not an amazing thrower but
he is their leading rusher he is able to
produce big plays that Virginia offense
has been good the problem is the
Virginia defense has been bad I says
Notre Dame's not gonna be a defensive
struggle on this one so maybe take the
over I'm picking Notre Dame I just think
they're too talented right now for
Virginia is been fun watching Brice Hall
against chase Claypool who wins that
battle you have to marquee prospects
that are gonna be matched up out on the
outside but I think Ian's book is
just good enough at quarterback he's not
gonna turn the ball over he can do some
things with his legs and Virginia again
you're struggling against Old Dominion
that's a problem for me they that they
are undefeated they are ranked 18 that
beat Florida State
they beat William and Mary they beat
Pitt and they beat South Carolina in the
opener but those teams are bigger names
than they are bigger threats so I don't
believe in Virginia right now I'm sorry
Chris long I love you but I don't
believe in Virginia yeah and I agree
with you on this game I think if Notre
Dame wants to stay in that playoff hunt
which I feel like that locker room
probably believes they are still in
there with just one loss
you can't go back-to-back losses you
can't lose to two Virginia here you only
play a couple more ranked teams one of
those teams is Michigan they might not
be ranked when Notre Dame jeezum the
other one is USC they might not be
ranked when Notre Dame sees them so they
have to get this now ranked opponent
victory here coming off the Georgia loss
I was impressed by what I saw with Notre
Dame but I also know they're probably
going to be pretty beat up after having
to deal with the big boys in the SEC so
I'm gonna take Notre Dame but I'm
staying away from those points I'm not
touching that 12 and a half I think
Virginia can play them pretty close but
I do think Notre Dame comes out with the
win yeah that's a big line I think
FanDuel it opened up at 11 so we've
already seen this line all over the
place only getting bigger I like Notre
Dame a lot in this game it's got a great
prospect matchup in this game with chase
Claypool and Brice Hall if they line up
against each other I think Claypool has
been very good this year very good
against Georgia and once again Notre
Dame yes they lost but they went out on
the road against one of the best teams
in the country and really gave them
everything they had for all four
quarters I think they're playing at a
pretty high level right now and I know
Virginia is too
I just don't think Virginia has enough
to beat Notre Dame especially on the
road alright next game a big pac-12
showdown it's at 2:30 Central Time I
look I was looking for this game and
it's like with [ __ ] is this game it's at
2:30 Central Time it's an afternoon game
or a morning game if you're on the west
coast Connor will be at this game
actually just stuff for bleacher report
Washington is favored by 10 and a half
the over-under is at 60 and a half
here's the thing we don't know what to
expect from us ease offense because
they've net there are the third
quarterback and Mason Fink did look very
very good last week
I was 21 of 34 three touchdowns one
interception he looks good he looks like
okay man they beat Utah that's a good
Utah team and it was because he just
threw the ball to Michael Pittman jr.
you think should be the starter again
this week it looks like slovis is out
again I'm excited about the matchup this
is a very good albeit very young
Washington secondary two freshmen at the
corner positions miles Brian and strong
safety is very very good I expect that
we'll see some bracket coverage from
Elijah Moulton over the top of Michael
Pittman jr. I still believe that USC is
just an unknown at this point having to
travel to Seattle it's a young Club I'm
gonna pick Washington to win but I think
USC covers yeah you know I'm gonna agree
with you here I have no idea what kind
of team we have with USC there three and
one right now against some pretty good
opponents BYU Fresno State Utah which is
a game I did not think they would win
but they did and they've been very good
at home so far the problem with this
game is it's in Seattle and I don't
think many teams can travel up to
Washington and take on the Huskies
especially with the way that Jacob Eason
has played so far this year it really
looks like that offense has some things
going and if they can get the defense to
just slow down USC who is on their third
string quarterback with faint I think
that Washington can put up enough points
to beat USC so I agree with you Matt now
I'm taking Washington out right but I
would stay away from the ten and a half
point spread again because I do think
this is gonna be a close game four teams
ranked four spots apart ten and a half
points it's pretty disrespectful hitting
USC but like you said this is not an
easy place to play I think Washington
has been watching that Utah tape all
week and saying we're not letting that
happen on our secondary and Utah has a
lot of players in that secondary it was
kind of shocking how badly they got lit
up by Michael Pittman jr. I don't think
Washington is gonna lay down like that I
think it's gonna be maybe I'm wrong I
think it'll be a little reality check
for USC I don't think this game will
come down to the wire
I do think Washington wins by a
touchdown in this one and all eyes are
on Jacob Eason right now because there's
been so much conversation around - and
being the best guy which he is but then
you have Herbert from Jordan love Joe
Jacob Eason is like the horse around the
third leg of the race and you're like
whoa he was in eighth place and now he's
sneaking up into the top three I think a
lot of eyes are on him as an NFL player
right now yeah absolutely is he had a
great week last week I know a lot of
people been asking us about Jacob Eason
this is this would be a good test for
him against a more talented again a
young USC secondary but a good matchup
number 24 K state ghost is Stillwater to
take on Oklahoma State the Cowboys are
favored - four and a half over under 60
and a half Oklahoma State last week put
up points against our Texas Longhorns
which is not hard to do but they were
able to score I thought it was most
interesting that Texas was able to
really shut down Thailand Wallace who I
thought would have a big game I thought
Spencer Sanders and Thailand would tear
up a young Texas secondary that's
dealing with a lot of injuries they did
not our guy Chuba Hubbard still went off
so if your k-state you're looking at
this okay we have to stop the run game
Sanders 1 over 100 Hubbard 1 over 100
how can we do that the answer I don't
think they can so I'm picking Oklahoma
State in this one they are favored but
they're the unranked team in this one I
think what k-state I know they're
changing a lot of things with Bill
Snyder now gone we're seeing a little
bit more of an open offense with Gilbert
and Thompson I just don't think they
have the offensive firepower to keep up
with Oklahoma State yeah and that's
where I'm gonna agree with you again I
know that's real exciting but you're
right because Oklahoma State played with
Texas who is a good team and they were
able to score points with them - yes
that's a very young defense but still
you look at k-state they haven't played
anybody I think a lot of people want to
believe in Bill Snyder and that k-state
can be good without him but I just I
haven't seen it yet I think we're over
rating the wins that they have they
struggled with Mississippi State not
Tommy Stevens in Mississippi State
the freshman quarterback coming into his
first game that Mississippi State I
don't think you can struggle against
them and then go into Stillwater and
expect the same kind of production
Trouba Hubbard is just gonna be too much
so what are you gonna do you load the
box against Juba hubber and you say
you're not gonna rush for 250 today ok
good luck congratulations yeah now deal
with Thailand Wallace who do you have
that can deal with him and maybe you
bracket him you take him away well
Oklahoma state still has playmakers and
they also have Spencer
Anders who can get it done with his feet
so I do think that this point spread
here I'm taking Oklahoma State I don't
think this one is gonna be that close I
would take the spread here four and a
half points I think Oklahoma State gets
it done by a large margin yeah this is a
game where I really do like the line
here I'm actually shocked that Vegas
almost views them as even I know usually
three points for being obviously at home
so that's still really really close and
I don't think they are I think it comes
down to what both of you said offensive
firepower for Oklahoma State maybe this
game does reach into that over a line of
60 and a half there might be a lot of
points in this one there might be a lot
of quick scoring but it's pick your
poison with this Oklahoma State offense
at home and they're gonna get it done
alright here is a big one guys the
College GameDay will be at this one
number five Ohio State - 17 at Nebraska
over/under 66 and a half that's the
biggest over/under of any game or
preview in this weekend guys this is a
huge one Ohio State has been unstoppable
so far this year they've scored 45 40 to
51 and 76 points Miami of Ohio basically
quit last week after scoring five points
Ohio State is a juggernaut
Justin Fields has thrown 13 touchdowns
zero interceptions he is 66 of 95 for 13
touchdowns I can't do that on Madden and
Justin fields is doing it out there now
here's the thing playing in Lincoln a
night game is gonna be a little bit
different for Justin fields this is not
Miami of Ohio I'm sorry it's not Indiana
it's not Cincinnati it's definitely not
FAU the black shirts are gonna be rockin
it's gonna be red as hell in that
Stadium and you know the sky frost and a
quietly very good Adrian Martinez are
gonna be ready for this game I know a
lot of people were disappointed Martinez
came out a little slow in Week one he
has more yards passing the justin field
stuff little-known fact
inez getting it done on the ground
already 234 yards I know all that makes
it sound like I'm picking Nebraska I am
not picking Ohio State but I think
Nebraska covers because - 17 is
ridiculous for a home team I know Ohio
State is just smack and folks left and
right the other side of that they have
not been tested there has been zero
adversity for Ohio State this might be
the first time we get to see them
struggle
yeah and that's what I have in my notes
- we got to stop your green like this
but this game to me actually screams
Nebraska upset because this is a game
where we've seen Ohio State lose before
look at Purdue look at Iowa's teams that
they were supposed to roll on early in
the season but Urban Meyer and that
staff could not get it done so this game
really reminds me of one of those trap
games where Ohio State's saying well we
know we're better than Nebraska
we'll just take care of our business
here we'll move on to next week but I'm
telling you you better focus when it
comes to Nebraska because Scott frost
will have that team playing hard I do
think that Ohio State's gonna win this
game
I agree with you Matt when you say you
probably taking Nebraska with the points
I think this is gonna be a huge game for
chase young Adrienne Martinez has
already been sacked ten times this year
that line has struggled to protect him
and now you're facing one of the best
defensive linemen I have ever seen I
think that by the end of the day
Adrienne Martinez the sacked five times
they struggled to move the ball I like
Ohio State big in this one and it's
because of the defense I think will
maybe see a little regression from
Justin field but this defense is gonna
get the job done for him yeah cross the
board this is one of the best offensive
lines in the country and that is not
good news for Nebraska I know there's a
lot of excitement it's a night game
Nebraska has a special football culture
I guess what I don't give a [ __ ] if this
game was on the moon and Ohio State
didn't have helmets they would still win
this game by a lot of points they have
too much firepower on offense Ryan Day
is gonna go into this game and knowing
it's a trap game knowing they're gonna
get 200 percent from Nebraska
it doesn't matter Ohio State's defense
will come out ready
I do think Ohio State's offense will be
a little slow in the first two quarters
but at the end of the day it's too much
get JK Dobbin Dobbins involved get those
great wide receivers a lot of looks and
targets and get Justin fields on the
move I know he's a big quarterback with
a big arm but he can use his legs Ohio
State wins big in this one on the road
yeah one thing I'll say about this game
before we move on to the blind review
I'm really surprised how little KJ Hill
is getting involved like Ohio State Nia
KJ Hill the ball last year it seemed
like join Haskins had his number this
year it's just it hasn't been there for
the Ohio State offense energy
kay Dobbins has just been the man for
them say haven't they ever had to throw
the ball a whole lot but I think he's
someone who has to step up this week all
right Bobby has just been crystal
baseband the new Terry there he's been
so good by the way can people start
crediting us for the nickname I was
gonna ask you guys did anyone else call
him scary Terry don't think so and I'm
kind of sitting there like wait a minute
other people know about this yeah and
then other people are like oh he's
maclaurin like f1 or one and I'm just
like no that is scary Terry and that
comes take two folks I'll get mellow
credit he's the first one that said it
in the press box in Mobile and I thought
it was hilarious so I started saying it
and it just kind of took off it became I
thought it was me but I'm not gonna
watch I'll give I think it was Connor
too but we definitely came up with it on
stick to football we made it a thing
because of Terry Rozier with the cell
exactly and then we made it into a scary
Terry thing here so if you see that
nickname floating out there like Oh nada
coast-to-coast scouting you can have
danger zone okay that was definitely
they did a good job at that and Kieffer
that should catch on but scary Terry was
definitely stick to football all right I
just want to get that off my chest
Connor congratulations that's the best
nickname in the NFL but we want some
[ __ ] credit for it okay okay all
right there we go all right blind review
time it's back by popular demand
Philadelphia Eagles one in two Green Bay
Packers three you know the Packers are
favored - for over/under 47 but Melo
what happened Thursday night Aaron
Rodgers is what happened and he finally
started to get going with this offense
we've been waiting for it the defense
has bailed him out in a couple of these
games but we finally see that marquee
Aaron Rodgers performance with the three
touchdowns no interceptions this thing
game able to move around the pocket with
his feet he shows that he's still one of
the best quarterbacks in the league if
the Eagles just had maybe a little bit
more production at that receiver
position you can really tell that Carson
Wentz was struggling to get the ball in
the playmakers hands the running game
couldn't get going for the Eagles this
is a huge game for the Packers this
solidifies them as one of the top teams
in the NFC I think and the Eagles
they're gonna have to go back to the
locker room and figure out what kind of
team are they are they gonna run the
ball
who's their marquee receiver who did
they get the ball to it can't just go
through Earth's every time so the Eagles
they got a lot of work to do here after
a tough loss in Green Bay they do have a
lot of work to I really thought we would
see more mile Sanders I thought we'd see
more Zach Ertz especially with the
Packers not being super strong at the
safety position but my players of the
game the Smith Brothers that pass rush
for the Green Bay Packers able to get to
Carson Wentz able to affect him and I'll
say it Carson Wentz does not look the
same this year something I don't know if
it's still the injuries I don't know
what's going on but he does not look the
same they were able to really rattle him
so hats off to the Smith Brothers the
Packers go to four and oh yeah the
Packers are just cruising full throttle
right now Jerry Alexander may be the
best young cornerback in football and
they got Aaron Jones running the ball
they got Jamal Williams aka Sponge Bob
the mermen out there having a good time
and the Eagles the good Zach Ertz
Classic Zach Ertz game Nelson Aguilar no
drops the bad mile Sanders another
fumble and the Eagles still have no pass
rush right now so the Eagles they got to
make good game against the Jets but damn
you better make good on that game
because it is not looking good after
Thursday Night Football
impeachment time here at stick to
football and I swear to god we will
stick to football on this I will mention
no one it was currently under
investigation for impeachment I ain't
even gonna whistle on this segment what
are you talking about it but we are
gonna give you the five people 15 people
that we would like impeached from sports
I'm gonna start at number five guys
Roger Goodell got it go I think he's
gotten better but still get out of here
Roger we want you gone I think after
this next CBA we actually see the league
push him out a little bit number four on
my list
I love sports media and I feel like so
proud to be a part of that group but I
don't like Clay Travis so if we could
push him he's like the guy at our table
that's making us not cool he's like the
guy in high school that's like picking
on you know all the kids and like giving
us a bad reputation that's clay Travis -
sports media spreading rumors about
other people right like get him out of
there he's a mean girl at the table
that's not cool anymore get out of here
go go tune your Camaro or something man
number three Mark Emmert I hate the
n-c-double-a and everything they say you
could just say that Dan C double
let's just burn it down and start over
because they're absolutely terrible
every decision they make is the wrong
decision don't do it get out of here
number two Monday Night Football
I want a game on Monday night but just
stop everything you're doing is not
working the schedule sucks the booth
relationship is not good nothing is good
about this product other than the fact
that it's football on Monday night and
we're gonna watch it because we've
always watched it so we're gonna keep
watching it but it's not good TV anymore
so let's change it let's just completely
scrap it and I know they won't because
like ratings are good so ads are good
but your [ __ ] TV show sucks so maybe
change it because if you can't keep me
interested
you're losing your fan base and I'm
telling you you can't keep me interested
it's it's like the office after Michael
Scott leaves and you're right well I've
been watching out a whole damn thing I'm
gonna keep watching Monday Night
Football it's still not a great product
Lee it or like that show Nashville for
me that's my example like they change
what networks in like new show runners
and like I'm just I want to see how it
ends I'm gonna watch it but please God
let someone change Monday Night Football
and the number one thing that I would
impeach from sports I'm so over the top
done with this the only person that I
might like I don't know anyone I like
less than him Antonio Brown please go
the [ __ ] away I hope Eric Weddle
actually puts him in a hole and covers
that hole with enough dirt that he can
still breathe but we never hear from him
again I am so done with Antonio Brown
like go away dude
just stop to people I know you can guess
one that I would like to see lose their
Twitter accounts Antonio Brown is one be
on that list
I agree with you I'm gonna run down my
five we'll start with number five I
don't hate everybody on my list but
there's one there's one and he's just
got to go and that's Chris Berman for me
it dude they keep throwing him back in
our face I'm done with it like let the
guy retire you can't make ESPN Plus
happen we're not going to subscribe to
it a fetch even if you give us boom and
TJ hey I'm not paying that money to
watch this guy just let him retire he
the homerun Derby has been bad with him
there
boom go off and retire enjoy some drinks
enjoy some golfing circle the wagons and
write off exactly I just I don't need to
see him anymore
I think this the second or third time
that I've at least heard rumors of Oh
Sunday night countdown it is back I know
it is this time but just come on let it
let him go
he retired for a reason I'm sure they
throw a lot of money at him and they say
hey we need you back for this and he's
there but what the guy live a little bit
okay next one for me is Danny canal
who is this clown me he's only famous
for wearing the turtleneck nobody gives
a [ __ ] about his opinions he's almost
always wrong he gets blasted on Twitter
daily I just I hate watching his Twitter
I disagree with almost every opinion
that he's ever had I think so we just we
got to get rid of him why don't we keep
putting a microphone in front of his
face
why did we keep reading the tweets get
rid of Danny canal the next one hits
home for me it's long overdue he just
needs to retire he needs to go off into
the sunset Lee Corso is absolutely
terrible
oh-oh controversial absolutely terrible
on game day he can barely speak anymore
he gets everything wrong he's cursed on
the air when he's not supposed to it's
not like me sitting here saying [ __ ]
he's not supposed to do it on national
TV they have the guy it's like I'll give
them credit we're probably not supposed
to they have a good show there they have
good personalities it's time to let Lee
Corso go and if he's not gonna do it on
his own
somebody's gonna have to force him out
so I'm impeaching Lee Corso I used to
love him with the head gear and
everything but really we don't need to
see it anymore that crowd before you
that crowd is gonna get rowdy without
they can do it on their own he'll let
David Pollock put on some head gear like
nobody cares about that anymore it's
just a gimmick get Lee Corso out of
there next guy since I'm already poking
the flames a little bit here I hate Tony
Romo I cannot stand to watch games with
Tony Romo as the broadcaster one game
that I did like to watch him play or
sorry broadcast was the Chiefs game
because he backed all right two minutes
left here Chiefs are probably just gonna
believe the clock oh [ __ ] Pat mahomes
threw another touchdown I he said that
which the chief should bleed the clock
play for the second half year and the
chief scored two more touchdowns in that
half
I'm over the predict a net thing you see
other guys do it he was just the first
one Matt Hasselbeck can predict what the
defense is doing and what the offense is
supposed to on Thursday Night Football
like congratulations you played
quarterback I'm just kind of over it
it's nothing spectacular it was cool in
the beginning awesome but now I'm just
kind of over it and the number one guy
which I think is gonna be a common theme
here
it's got to be Mark Emmert in the NCAA
that is the absolute worst organization
in all of sports maybe the entire
country
they're so stuck in their ways they're
unable to listen to what any of their
players want who they're supposed to be
protecting the schools they don't help
them out either I think everybody has
just come to a point where we're fed up
with the NCAA and that starts with Mark
Emmert get some new leadership in there
that it's at least willing to work with
the players help out the schools it's a
win for everybody but we got to get rid
of mark Inman yeah he's got to go he's
got to go all right my my top five and
for Lee Corso man he's just an old man
having fun having some fun out there
damn in a hole number five for me James
Dolan yes he owns two of my favorite
teams the New York Knicks in the New
York Rangers my goodness is he awful and
he is just an awful person he's a shitty
owner he's ruined the Knicks for god
knows how many years the Rangers have
persevered because I believe this man
does not give a [ __ ] about hockey even
though he owns the team James Dolan go
player kazoo and leave us the [ __ ] alone
number four Joe Torre this one will
surprise a lot of people Joe Torre is
from Brooklyn and he is the spokesperson
for the MLB that does not let let the
Mets wear FDNY and NYPD and Port
Authority police hats on 9/11 and they
ask him why and he says I understand
it's an issue but then it would open the
door for other teams to wear whatever
they want it's a uniform issue but the
Houston Astros were allowed to wear
Apollo 11 moon landing moon landing
memorial hats and they asked him why and
he goes well I thought the only wort
during batting practice they didn't they
weren't during the [ __ ] game so the
Mets should just wore the hats because
clearly a guy that works in a high-level
job for the MLB is not watching the
games all right number three NCAA
nonsense not going to touch it you guys
did a great job no
to officiating TV analyst every time
there's a booth review they bring in a
guy that used to be a ref you recognize
his face because you watch football
every single Sunday and he explains why
the booth got it right even though
they're always wrong I don't need an
explanation of why it was right when
it's always wrong stop bringing them in
it's a waste of time during the
broadcast go back to football number one
MLB home plate umpires they can stand
there they can make the calls at the
plate but guess what make it robotic put
an earpiece in their ear and tell them
if it was a baller strike because these
guys have no [ __ ] idea what a strike
zone is they're always wrong
this happens every year and people for a
nostalgic reasons they're like no the
OMPs need to be human let them stand
there pay them the same salary I don't
care just get balls and strikes right we
do not need home plate UMP calling
pitches anymore
I love Connor all varieties because I
agree with you on like all of them the
Joe Torre thing absolutely ridiculous
and then the umpires at home play like
seriously put it in their ear and just
let them say yeah we don't need any more
UMP shell I'm with you 100%
I also think it's time to put a [ __ ]
laser in a football and not do the first
down chains anymore that's a good one
we've talked about why cuz they want the
drama of the measurement this is I've
seen those refs fumble the ball in a
team back and forth like yes the one
where the guys like oh [ __ ] which side
of my foot did i frakkin mark this ball
with yeah well just give them the extra
six first down it's a game of inches but
we're gonna let [ __ ] 60 year old guys
determine where the ball goes I mean
those drafts come to give me an extra
six inches I would love to be six foot
three all right let's go for happy six
four that's math all right let's take a
break we'll come back and knock out some
of your questions in draft on draft it
is draft on draft time first question
from at RCM underscore 52 put a name on
your account my goodness alright is it
time to create a new division in college
football create the FPS playoff
subdivision for the power five and keep
the FBS for the group of five teams team
can still play across divisions in
conference games uh I don't understand I
like it so what you saying is we have
the two divisions right now we have the
Bowl Subdivision we have the
championship
I got it we're not giving anybody
outside the power five I should have
power five and then you would have like
the mid 500 5 yeah because they're not
playing in the playoffs like let Notre
Dame but then they would have their own
championship but let them play in some
bowl games or some other [ __ ] like
that no I like it because really that's
what we're doing already you might as
well just make I agree I feel like this
is like that second wild-card team a
baseball like no one gives a [ __ ] I love
it this is like a participation trophy I
know I'm pears if it weren't for the
second one time it worked it's like the
playing game to the tournament no one
gives a [ __ ] about those teams I do I
want to see it because I want to see him
match up with each other probably give
every kid in your class at be like oh
he'll be hard today let me get my B I
have been religiously watching the Mets
standings for that second wild card spot
three months three months I've been
watching it yeah this would this would
probably upset some people but the
reality of the situation is it should
happen I think that's a really good
point buy a good old RCM there I just
don't want to hand out more trophies
like everybody's already getting one
though why I don't want it to happen
just the real reason I don't want UCF
you see I want to [ __ ] I knew this UCF
though yeah but then they could lose
maybe and then you don't have to worry
about them anymore yeah the way they
would have to join an actual conference
if you want to play with the big dogs
yeah well maybe that would can I go back
a segment Connor why didn't you have Tom
Brady on your top five in people's
impeachable people because it's just I
can't do that okay I can't do it no
there's no reason to impeach him just
cuz he beats the Jets and everyone else
in the world like everyone else I felt
like I had a valid argument of why they
suck but Tom Brady's just great it sucks
but it's true yeah all right next
question I just like to balance around
Daniel Reese if you could go back and
reevaluate a prospect you missed on who
would it be
I'll let you guys go first sure for me
it was the Neal hunter I did not think
he would be this good and I thought LSU
he was okay I didn't think he was a
superstar in college now he had all the
raw traits to develop into a phenomenal
pass rusher and he has he's a top ten
top five whatever you want to call it
pass rusher edge rusher in the league
and I think I just I didn't do a good
enough job evaluating the raw traits
from a school that has tons of players
that are just loaded up with traits that
turn into great NFL players so mine is
pretty obvious I happen to say that our
Lord and Savior Pat mahomes was gonna be
a bad quarterback mm he's okay at that
position I think he's doing all right
so maybe I should go back and look at
some of that Texas Tech tape with more
of an unbiased eye this time instead of
being I can't read Raider he sucks it's
a system as someone who's done that can
I tell you what you'll find
you won't like him if you go back and
watch Texas Tech you'll actually be like
okay I still don't get it he went to the
school of Andy Reid for a year not it
hats traits so if you go back and watch
Tech you're like okay yes he has a
strong arm and he's a gunslinger and
he's a little bit wild and like that's
all there but Andy Reid took that took
that clay and made him into like the
Statue of David
I don't think Andy gets enough credit
for that and I hat gets credit for
working hard learning I mean to do that
in a year is incredible but I think Andy
deserves looks like Tom Brady and
Belichick like those two go hand-in-hand
one would not be the other you know so I
agree with you that Pat mahomes was
special obviously we're seeing great
talent on the field but Andy Reid should
get some credit too because his ability
to use Pat mahomes develop him the way
that he has has been amazing but I
either way I clearly missed on that one
my obvious one would be Trent Richardson
but that's such a fun gag for me that I
don't want to change it like I just want
I'm okay with that review I think mine
that god there's so many cuz I've been
doing this a long time and this job is
really hard
I actually was way too high on Teddy
Bridgewater and even like even if you
told me he never got hurt and he played
the last three years he was never going
to become what I hoped he would be you
know like the accuracy in the football
IQ the poise he had those things but he
just he's so physically limited he was
never gonna hit that top ten quarterback
tear he was always gonna be an Alex
Smith type guy which is fine that's a
good quarterback but to have him ahead
of Jadeveon Clowney or Khalil Mack or
Odell in that class was just
irresponsibly bad for me so that's the
one where
knowing what I know now about
quarterback evaluation I would love to
go back and redo you know basically all
quarterback evaluation would be would be
fun for me all right next up Carson
Fritchie can you give us an insight what
you would do with the Bears quarterback
situation versus what you think is going
to happen I do weekly radio in Chicago
so this is something I actually been
talking about a lot and I think the only
thing they can do is wait you just have
to wait and see
Mitch was better last week and I know it
was against Washington so maybe that's
hard to have a takeaway about he has
struggled this year I think you can look
at his accuracy and say it has not been
where you would hope it would be in his
second year in this Matt naggy system I
also don't think it doesn't look like
there's a lot of offensive chemistry
with this team right now I know we all
want to point the fingers out the
quarterback all the time but I think the
o-line he's been sacked eight times in
three games they deserve some of the
credit the wide receiver core you can
tell they're off at times the run game
hasn't gotten going that can be pointed
a lot of different directions so I don't
think you can do anything chase Daniel
is your backup you still don't have a
ton of picks Oakland as your first-round
pick because the Khalil Mak trade so
it's not like you're gonna go out and
draft a guy in round one you're really
kind of stuck at least for this season
and next and the plan has to be to now
build an offense around Mitch they can
work right and I think they started that
with bringing in David Montgomery who
they're still not utilizing fully but
maybe bringing in some more offensive
linemen a via free agency or some
receivers via the draft I think you have
to surround him with pieces because you
can't go all in and say all right we're
gonna draft another quarterback you've
already given up too much to draft and
acquire other people on this team like a
Khalil Mak so I think that what I would
do is you're probably just gonna have to
ride it out with him try to surround him
with great pieces try to get these young
guys involved and I actually I think
that's what Chicago will do - yeah I
think they just unfortunately have to
rely on the guys around him to make
plays and I know that's a tough
situation this is a quarterback that
many people believed he would take them
to the next level and win them games I
think you're gonna have to really rely
you're gonna have to get David
Montgomery more involved that is a fact
there is no doubt about that because he
is somebody that can create missed
tackles and create his own yards but
where's the creativity which
remember the kind of pass-catching
weapon he was guys and we know how good
Alan Robinson is hopefully Trey Burton
can be the guy that we believe he can I
don't know how much better
Mitch himself is going to get and when
you have that with a very promising team
this is a defense that doesn't just stop
teams they score points you basically
just have to pick him up and that's what
the Bears are gonna have to do until
they can look for a different solution
if it doesn't get much better you know
the end the thing is this defense is
good enough you're gonna win enough
ballgames that you're probably not going
to be in quarterback territory and round
one no they won't be they would not be
so it becomes a tricky situation
Jeremy Godin one of the new members of
the stick to Football Hall of Fame he
asked is there a scenario where we see
to or from return for their senior year
something I've been saying for about a
month on the shows I think from will
return for his senior year he does not
seem to me like the kind of guy who will
come out early he's not going to get top
ten grades I think he would right now
probably get a fringe round one round
two grade so I think it's a return to
school for from - a it could happen he
is the number one quarterback in this
class with a bullet I don't see anyone
catching him I don't see I mean I can't
imagine anyone catching - of from my
opinion and the opinion of people I've
talked to around the league so I could
see from going back but not - I agree I
could see from coming back and saying
you know what - is gone let me see if I
can win a national championship or or
get an SEC Championship at least because
I do think that's important to him I
think he's one of those guys that takes
pride in what he's doing at the college
level and I'm sure - it does as well but
at the same time I think he's probably
eager and ready to move on to the next
level I don't I don't see a situation
where - it would ever return I don't
know what he has left to prove I don't
think that he's gonna say you know what
I need to come back and win the Heisman
he already has a national championship
so I think that he's gone after this
year I think so - it would be crazy for
him to stay and I know how good Alabama
is but at the end of the end to has been
hurt before - so don't risk it I mean
you're a great player you're probably a
number one pick at least a top five pick
go ahead get out you know and for from I
think Matt you know matt has been
eluding for a while that it looks like
there's a good chance prom kits
things could always change but it makes
a little more sense because also maybe
we'll see Fromm's arm get a little bit
stronger as he gets older and goes into
a senior year maybe that'll improve his
stock and more importantly if you're a
Georgia team you can convince a couple
guys to stay and go for an Atty yeah
because I mean they're close I think we
all believe this is a very talented team
last question from Nicole Antonio what's
your ideal football Saturday or Sunday
look like for example she doesn't like
red zone or going to bars she prefers to
be home watching two games on two TVs
and buffalo chicken dip is a must I feel
like there you go there's my perfect
Saturday - I think it just depends like
I really enjoyed watching the Texas
Oklahoma State game in a bar Saturday
night with all our listeners like that
was fun for me but it you can't really
like watch the game as closely as you
would like - I did come home and watch
the game again on Sunday night because
you miss things time especially if
you're drinking as much as we're
drinking yeah I think like that can be
fun but if I if I could have it in my
way it would be 45 degrees outside and
overcast I would be in a hoodie and some
warm socks under a blanket with a pot of
chili some Fritos some shredded sharp
cheddar cheese a 12-pack of Boulevard
wheat and I would have two TVs because I
think more than that you
you just can't you're not watching them
right after this is on so you can take a
picture for Instagram - TV's sure one
was sound one muted and I would actually
put one on red zone and one on a game
like the game of the week because I do
want to know what's happening around the
league
but I don't want to like hyper focus so
one for red zone one for whatever the
big game is yeah I I agree with you I do
like to do the two TVs I think she hit
the nail on the head there because
you're right after that you're really
just you're not paying attention all
three you can't do that so red zone yes
then a game you're watching whether it's
your your team or the game of the week
whatever's going on I like going to bars
- it's very exciting to watch games with
the people who are really invested but
at the same time you're right because
you can't get into it you can't hear
what's going on as well so I'm gonna say
at home as well with the two TV setup
that's great me and Matt grew up
together so our ideal like football
watching
situation it's like ideal I kind of go
back to mom and dad's house right I know
the brand of chili you're talking about
for frito pies and stuff like that so I
get it that's probably mine too I think
my first college football Saturday will
be week eight so I don't even know what
those are like at home anymore yeah
they're always on the road constantly on
the road but Sunday's you guys know this
after tailgate tours I usually like to
fly out at the crack of dawn so I'm home
for NFL Sunday and that's where I like
to spend it at home on the couch like
you said two TVs this month during
September once in a while we'll get a TV
up on the roof we'll hook up like a MiFi
so the stream is good and good quality
watch maybe Sunday Night Football or the
late games up there but like you guys
said get a good pack of beer have a ton
of food out have redzone on one of the
TV's the main game you want to watch on
the other you can flip around if you
need to but you're not gonna be focusing
on 50 different things and honestly my
favorite ways of watching football is
being home and I think the less we're
around for that the more I appreciate it
yes yeah I know that we sponsor a tour
where we go out and we watch football
games but football is really good at
home I mean definitely come out to our
tailgate tour spots but catch some other
games at home it's not a bad deal Monday
Thursday listeners like you come to a
game on the tailgate tour when we're in
your city for us it's like we're at 19
games or whatever it's like ah god I
missed my couch uh-huh I spend a lot of
money on that couch and I don't never
can sit on it too much you miss being
out it's just gonna balance you know I
hate being alone like I really don't
want to know that yeah I like to be
around people and I right now I'm
craving being alone so bad and it's
never gonna happen again so uh well
that's a little peek inside my my psyche
right now but I think that's a good
tweet us or leave your iTunes would be
what is your ideal football weekend a
stick to football on Twitter leave it in
the youtube comments or make it your
podcast review we definitely appreciate
those Connor and I'll be back Monday
afternoon I believe shake your head if
you I'm right Connor will be back Monday
afternoon with a show yes videos not out
on the road and then Wednesday morning
of course breaking it all down if you
want a mock draft from us
next week let us know tell us you want
it we'll make it happen for Conor and
mellow
we will talk to y'all real soon